[Music]
i had seen in the past
complex deals but i'd never seen
anything like this
and it involved two of europe's leading
financial institutions on the one hand
the world's oldest bank and italy's
third largest lender to monte paske
and on the other hand deutsche bank
wants the world's largest financial
institution
the idea that these two had got together
to cook the books was just astonishing
i thought it was clever but illegal
and a few of them should actually go to
jail in my view
this was clearly a huge scandal that
made
450 million dollars disappear from monte
paske's books
if it wasn't for for our reporting the
public may never have found out
[Music]
my name is elisa martinuzzi i'm a
columnist with bloomberg opinion
a presidential address to the nation
this is an extraordinary period for
america's economy
over the past few weeks many americans
have felt anxiety about their finances
and their future
so it's december 2008 and we're right in
the depth of financial crisis
the dow tumbled more than 500 points
after two pillars of the street tumbled
over the weekend
financial institutions are really
fighting for survival
and you know these two in particular
monte paske
and deutsche bank we're seeing the stock
falling by more than seven percent as we
speak right now
on the one hand you have deutsche bank
with a massive balance sheet you know
two and a half trillion euros it's the
size of a large economy
trust that the bank is solid and sound
is what it needs to retain every day to
keep ticking along
so showing that it's able to do a deal
like the one it was trying to do with
pasqui
is absolutely critical
and you have monte de pasque which just
recently bought a big rival
at the peak of the market in cash or
already stretching its finances
suddenly was facing another 450 million
dollars potentially in in a single loss
and a single investment
that it would have to book at 2008.
they couldn't admit the loss that they
actually had faced
and so this deal was to cover that loss
the risk they were facing was
nationalization by the italian
government or control by the bank of
italy direct
it was a prospect that management was
trying everything it possibly could
to avert they come up with this complex
multi-layered transaction which like
magic
takes the loss that they would have to
crystallize at the end of 2008
and spreads it out over many years in a
fashion that they decide that doesn't
have to be disclosed to
investors and of course it's structured
in such a way
that deutsche bank would in the long run
make a great deal of money from this
so something in the order of 60 million
euros just on that trade
the whole point of it was to violate the
accounting requirements
of of italy and fool the accounting
structure
stop them having it essentially to
account for a loss
as simple as that
it wasn't long after they struck the
deal that montepalski
started hurting from the transaction
marty daposky's just revealed it could
run out of cash in just
four months it needs to offload a
mountain of bad loans
or risk being wound down yet pesky
limped along
propped up by government bailout after
losses on bad loans also piled up
astonishingly it took more than four
years for the chicanery to come to light
well after regulators from the u.s to
italy had been alerted to it
a tipster reached out and said you know
i have something for you that's going to
be of great interest and there
started my reporting on monte paske
little by little the source got
comfortable
in sharing more and more details about
this transaction that to be honest with
you
looked really too good to be true
the material when looked at it in its
completeness
you know spoke quite clearly of what was
going on this transaction that
had allowed the world's oldest bank
to basically cook its books so what i
endeavored to do was to find
experts in the field who would help
stand up um what what these transactions
were
were trying to do you know help
substantiate what the source was telling
me
and one of these was professor michael
dempster
from cambridge i had seen in the past
complex deals but i'd never seen
anything like this where
basically it was shifting cash back and
forth in time
so a simple version of how the deal
worked goes something like this
you had two parts one was sure to win
for monterey paske and one was sure to
lose for monterey pesky
the part that was sure to win would
generate a gain from monte de pasque
which you would use
to cover up the existing norths the part
that was sure to lose for monterey pesky
the italian bank would keep
but it wouldn't crystallize that loss
right at 2008
it would spread out the loss over many
years what was striking was the fact
that the client was being given a huge
amount
of money a half a billion euros roughly
speaking
we'd never seen a deal like this in
which the client received
a large amount of cash at the beginning
and paid it back
and then some afterward when when i saw
it and
when uh lisa martinez saw it
i mean it's obvious that it's
it's an illegal accounting device
so initially it was a sienna prosecutors
that started looking at these
transactions
and it went to trial about three years
ago
and the verdict came in november
milan court convicted 13 individuals for
helping monte paske hide losses from its
accounts
the individuals included montepaschi's
former chairman giuseppe mustre
and deutsche bank's former head of
global rates mikhail
to be able to serve to customize
solutions
the judges also ordered the banks to pay
fines and set aside amounts that total
160 million
and ordered further inquiries into some
of the individuals who had testified
these are by a number of measures the
most significant convictions
relating to the financial crisis you
haven't had
chairman of institutions let alone 13
senior managers across three
institutions
go to face jail sentences for their
wrongdoing
but of course this is convicted in an
italian court they have they don't have
to go to jail
unless they have a second trial in which
they essentially can
put them in jail so whilst they've
been besmirched so to speak their
reputations
it's not terribly huge punishment
my initial response to the verdicts was
that they were not
stiff enough and they should have gone
another layer up to in fact
uh you know the head of the investment
bank
i'm not so sure that the public can
really be confident that we're not going
to see another monteposky
the situation is essentially the same
today as it was before
a lot more complicated because the
regulators have tried to make it better
but they failed basically having spoken
to regulators
about the lessons from the financial
crisis it's pretty clear where the
weaknesses still lie
generally on all the reforms that i've
done since the financial crisis
we've made them better but we probably
haven't made them good enough so there's
there's really not been
fundamental changes we've kind of made
these improvements around the edges
i think people should still be concerned
and think there's this kind of
assumption that
it's yesterday's news and i think that's
probably
ill-advised because i think there's
still some real fragility in the system
as a senior investment banking executive
recently told me
his chief financial officer would not be
able to challenge him
on on what's in his box you need a phd
to understand a lot of these
transactions
and you know the people in charge are
often
don't have those phds it is not an awful
lot to be confident about
what's really lurking inside financial
institutions balance sheets
and it remains just as difficult for the
outside world to get into them
yes it's true the higher management
often doesn't understand
much at all actually which of course is
a serious problem
when there is a crisis not unlike what
we saw
in the lead-up to the global financial
crisis where it was mortgage debt
that had ballooned this time it's
corporate debt
the market has grown enormously and
i believe that there's a recession
coming
or a market crash coming and it's a
government matter it's a political
matter and
whether or not the politicians will be
able to sort something out
i'm very pessimistic about that
[Music]
you